el calor infernal en portugal alimenta
agresivos incendios frente a muros de
llamas cerca de 3.000 bomberos e incluso
los habitantes que intentan combatir el
fuego con sus propios medios ramen esta
mañana sentí pánico veía los
helicópteros ahora de noche veo hasta
qué punto su horrible papel si melocos y
las llamas avanzan desde hace tres días
este vecino observa impotente como su
casa se reduce a cenizas más cerca del
bosque esta otra casa quedó calcinada
fue muy rápido de repente hubo mucho
humo y la casa estaba en llamas no
podemos hacer nada más
croacia también estás sofocada por las
llamas
frente a un macro incendio los
habitantes intentan contener el fuego
ayudados por bombarderos de agua apenas
visibles en un cielo lleno de humo
pero todavía arde a 150 metros de aquí
no tenemos que ir a ver intentar frenar
este fuego
carreras contrarreloj contra nuevos
focos de incendio
el agua imprescindible para andar en
españa donde sobre todo en el centro y
en el sur del país se llega a los 40
grados desde la mañana es un infierno
solo por andar puede darte un golpe de
calor en reinounido las playas están
abarrotadas aquí hay profesionales del
turismo que sonríen ante estas
temperaturas extremas es fantástico
nosotros vivimos para esto por esto
hacemos negocio sin embargo los
servicios de emergencias médicas están
en alerta aparte de los casos menores
habituales llegan problemas serios de
insolaciones y golpes de calor a la ola
de calor continuará esta semana y cada
vez se esperan más episodios parecidos
como consecuencia del cambio climático